This world wasn't always so small and petty
Thousands of years ago while the rest of men prayed to gods the Valyrians became them
through magic or sheer will they mastered the greatest creatures in history a
Horse grunts man dominion over the land a ship over the sea
but dragons gave us the sky and
Everything and everyone beneath it
At its height my ancestors ruled the known world
Whatever parts we didn't Wentworth known
Our capital of Valyria shamed the Magnificent cities of the East for hammers and chisels
Were no match for Dragon Fire and sorcery
It was a city and an empire built to last until the end of time
It didn't
400 years ago the doom fell on Valyria
mountains cracked open like eggs lakes and rivers boiled fountains of fire ash and smoke
Spewed from the ground so high and so hot that even dragons burned in a flight
The land splintered and the angry sea rushed in
In hours the greatest city in history
became history
But my ancestors didn't burn nor drown with the rest of their race
12 years before the doom despite the sneers of his rivals
Aina Targaryen abandoned the capital with his family
Legends claim that his daughter foresaw the destruction of the city in a dream
More likely a nar met with some mishap at court and chose exile over execution
He and House Targaryen
slicked away to a dreary remote godforsaken Island
forsaken no longer
With arts now lost to the world
We transformed a tiny outpost into Dragonstone a fortress fit for the last dragon Lords
Then a nars descendants settled into it like a tomb for their lost homeland
Until ago
When he looked east he saw the past old tired dead
but when he lived West
He saw the future
gold in the world
gold in the fields and no dragons in the sky, but is
He and his sisters Rhaenys and Visenya
flew over the great continent ostensibly visitors to a strange land
But when Aegon returned he ordered construction of a massive table?
carved in the shape of Westeros with all the notable rivers and mountains that they had seen a
personal map of the Seven Kingdoms
Then ruled by seven squabbling families
House Durrendon held the Stormlands from their seated storm's end due south of Dragonstone
House Hoar of the Iron Islands had also conquered and enslaved the Riverlands and ruled them from Harrenhal a
monstrous castle rising on the shore of the Gods I
How stark held the frozen wasteland of the North the oldest largest and emptiest of the kingdom
As lannister held the westerland's the wealthiest kingdom. Thanks to their gold mines
House gardener held the reach of the second wealthiest Kingdom. Thanks to their crops
As Aaron held the Vale or rather the Vale held them the mountains were impassable except through the bloody gate
Which had never been taken
House martell alt the deserts are doomed
From the plate because no one else wanted them
Together the seven kingdoms made Westeros a realm that wasn't yet a realm
ruled by great families who didn't know what greatness was
Aegon would teach them
Hey everybody big surprise HBO dropped this big history bonus feature in advance of season 8 like they're getting ready to drop the DVDs later
This year sometimes they produce
Animated content for stuff that the TV show isn't gonna deal with
which I'm also doing a giveaway for so all you have to do to enter that is just be a
subscriber and leave a game of Thrones comment on this video
I'll announce a new winner at the end of this
But the funny thing about this is that it's you know for the history of Valyria in the early history of the Targaryen family
But it's also narrated by Harry Lloyd the series so Daenerys his brother
Who's a very pompous person talks about ancient Valyria in a very pompous way?
It shouldn't be too much of a surprise that he thinks very highly of the people that he descends from but I like the way
That he talks about Aegon being a pragmatist
But just because he only conquered the Seven Kingdoms
After leaving Dragonstone doesn't mean that they didn't go back to the east a couple times during his lifetime
The other important thing about this is the idea that we haven't had a flashback to ancient, Valyria
And I think that's largely in favor of leaving that for one of the prequel series to deal with
So keep that in the back of your mind one of the five prequels that they're developing most of them are centered around big
Historical events the doom of Valyria or even the rise of, Illyria
Which I think is a better option is just one of those possibilities
So I believe that the version of this that they'll release with the DVD is actually gonna be longer
Because they sort of brush over a lot of early Valyrian history because as the Valerians learned to tame dragons they conquered the ghiscari
empire in order to rule that area of the kingdom and then obviously there are a lot of other places in the east that we
Haven't been yet. GT is this really big expansive area
That's actually much older than the Valyrian freehold and was much richer at its height
Which is why it's so funny to listen to Viserys talk about how amazing the Valyrians were because there are even older cultures
That felt ruined before them
But the cool thing about the freehold that's different from
Westeros is that they actually ruled by committee that was sort of like a ruling council you would elect archons
But each family had a financial interest in the freehold
And that was sort of their participation in the government like the Targaryen for instance were a relatively minor house
They weren't that big of a deal the reason why they're so big is because they had the foresight
Thanks to dan is the dreamer who had the vision of the doom to leave before everything ended up in flames?
They kind of brush over that and this but they do give you the idea that everybody thought that it was going to be this
Wonderful Kingdom that would live on forever, and they're all having this party here on top of this spire
And then it all just blows up so the thing that Viserys
Conveniently leaves out of this is that they used a lot of slave labor to build their empire in - so yes the Dragons gave
them great power
But a lot of their actual monetary wealth came from all the precious minerals in and around the 14 flames
but if you've ever heard of any of the
geological theories of why the doomed happened the ideas is that they might have been on a fault line in
hundreds of years of over mining just
Destabilized the area in and around the volcanoes causing them to erupt again
So the idea was is that it wasn't all of them
Erupting at once it was one going off and then that sending off a chain reaction
That caused the other fourteen flames to erupt and that's how when they say that everything went up in smoke and fire in hours
That's why it happened so quickly it was like an early event that set off a chain reaction
So it only seemed like it was happening very quickly
But because we know that magic exists in the world the children of the forest even
Smashed the arm of Dorne with the hammer of waters
There's also a lot of theories that there was some magical element that caused the fourteen flames to erupt so there haven't been any answers
about that George R
Martin hasn't painted any light on that only the idea that is this changing of the seasons the shifting of the balance of power
So you have R allure the red God creatures born of fire the Dragons?
Then you have the night King creatures born of ice the whites
But while I do think we'll continue to get Robert's rebellion
flashbacks during season eight maybe a couple brief ones because there's only six episodes just to sort of spell out the rest of Rhaegar and
Lyanna story is that they leave a lot of the Valyrian history for potential prequel series because it's just too rich and too
Interesting to not explore if you have the opportunity so just remember that there are five different stories
They're developing right now. The Blackfyre rebellion is another pick that George R. Martin has not shot down
There's a couple ideas that he said that they're definitely not doing
Robert's rebellion is one of them entails of Dunkin egg is the other those are the only two that he shot down so any other
Big historical event is toad up for grabs, and it doesn't necessarily have to be in Westeros
They did say some of the ideas were in the East which I think is a subtle way of
Confirming that one of the ideas is a Valyrian prequel, but let me know in the comments
What do you guys think about them producing this animated content?
What would you think about an adult?
Animated Game of Thrones series as long as it was adult and in keeping with the tone of Game of Thrones like you probably don't
Want the Disney Channel animated version of Game of Thrones that would just make people angry?
So because I wasn't expecting them to drop this my next game of Thrones video will be a character video
But congratulations to the latest giveaway winner miss Kerr
Please private message me on the back end of my channel so I can get your contact details there for the copies of the DVD
Now I'll name a new winner when I post new Game of Thrones
You can click here for brand new season 8 and you can click here for all my other Game of Thrones videos
Thank you so much for watching. Everybody stay awesome. I'll see you guys tonight